c'est moi un nouveau confinement que la
continuation du confinement mis en place
en allemagne en lice n 9 bat d'exemple
cependant y avoir des restrictions
supplémentaires pour pâques
cela a choqué beaucoup de gens car on
s'attendait à des assouplissements pour
cette période à une levée des
restrictions sur les comptes
les chiffres de la colline suggère que
cela ne serait pas du tout à viser les
opinions sont partagées quant à la
pertinence de cette continuation du
conseil docteur les professionnels de
santé pointe du doigt ces chiffres et 10
c'est un répit pour nous car les
hôpitaux a frôlé leur pleine capacité
dans ce scandale
et beaucoup se sont pris de vapeur tombe
en pâmoison face à cette décision
d'angela merkel
un des dirigeants des sept et allemands
ont pris lundi plus tôt mardi matin avec
15 négociations selon la chancelière
allemande est entrée dans une nouvelle
journée me car le nombre de cas de kovy
de grimper depuis environ une semaine
succès lundi jour et en ce moment à 108%
mille c'est à dire que 108 personnes
sont testées positives sur 100 m cela
dans son contexte
le frein d'urgence conçu va tout arrêter
si la tentation dégénère était supposé
être activé à 100 cas pour 100000
personnes ce qui est largement dépassée
guitare médiation toutefois scandalisé
et disent que le gouvernement veut
détourner l'attention du c'est
maintement notamment concernant les bacs
sont mécontents de mesures décidées
mardi au petit matin
bref des mesures ne demanderez vous les
équipes devront tenir leurs services en
ligne
cinq adultes seulement de deux foyers
maximum 3 avril et c'est sans doute ce
qui passe un mois sera le seul jour sur
les sacs de la période pascale ou les
supermarchés les ouvrir cela suscite
beaucoup de colère car les commerces
sont pratiquement complètement à l'arrêt
suite à cette région dans gala merkel et
des représentants des 16
les six titres seront requis pour toute
personne rentre en allemagne après les
vacances à l'étranger
il ya encore très peu de temps même si
beaucoup de choses ont changé dans
l'intervalle l'allemagne avait indiqué
que majorque était une destination
acceptable et beaucoup de personnes
avaient déjà pris des réservations ils
vont peut-être y repensez à deux fois
à propos d'astrazeneca ans qu'elle a
merkel a déclaré suite à sa réunion avec
les dirigeants locaux qu'elle soutenait
sur ce la banque vers l'ailleurs la
président de la commission m
et qu'il y avait selon ses propres
termes un problème avec cela von der
leyen a menacé ce week-end de bloquer
les exportations du vaccin
astrazeneca les doses produites sur les
territoires européens pourraient être
interdits d'exportation hors du bloc
jusqu à ce qu astrazeneca est tenu ses
engagements avec l'union aurez votre
contrat avec lieu d'abord c'est le
message ursula von der leyen qui sera
répétée lors d'un sommet européen
crucial ce jeu il faut mettre
la menace d'empêcher les exportations de
vaccins notamment vers le royaume uni
avec les conséquences que cela peut
avoir sur l'avenir des relations entre
le lieu et le royaume uni ou encore une
fois m recours directrice de l'agencé
européenne du médicament a annoncé jeudi
que les centres de production du vaccin
tué en russie serait contrôlé par des
agents de la m e elle n'a pas donné de
date mais cela intervient peu de temps
après la déclaration de thierry breton
chef du wild travaillent sur la
production de vaccins de la commission
européenne d adn selon lequel l'europe
n'a pas besoin du sponeck vie pour
certains le sujet politisé il semble
effectivement que cela soit au moins en
partie le cas mais la réalité du terrain
et qu'il n'y a pas assez de vaccins en
europe en ce moment plusieurs états
membres ont déjà acheté des doses de ce
sommet certains états membres et
disposerait même déjà échoué en
allemagne angela merkel affirmé qu'ils
seraient disposés à acheter des douze de
spots nick v mais attendent
l'autorisation de la m e à défaut
d'autorisation at elle également dit
l'allemagne pourrait avancer sur la peau
on a évoqué des investissements dans une
usine de bade wurtemberg qui pourrait
bien produire le spiegel en allemagne
sur le territoire européen
cela faciliterait la distribution auprès
d'une population très demandeuse de
vaccination le plan qui ne changent pas
en allemagne et d'offrir à tous ceux qui
le souhaitent la
six nations unies 6 septembre cela
semble extrêmement ambitieux à ce jour
mais je le répète c'est le blanc